good morning this is part three of
native accent I wanted to talk to you of
the details of what I call the phonetic
analysis
I chose Italian as an example on which
to apply the phonetic analysis but this
analysis can be applied pretty much in
every every language now before starting
and before showing the the markers that
like you like you to know that in the
Italian intonation has got some special
features the first one concerns words
isolated taken in isolation that means
that the main stress leshenka Kaneko
remain stress falls on one of the
syllabus that make up an Italian word
and this gives and the voice stops for a
microsecond they're giving Italian words
specific rhythm not only 20 time word
but also to an Italian sentence let's
let the tonic accents can be seen more
or less like a fourth tone in Chinese as
I said previously and this this one is
the marker that I used in order to
specify this main stress so the vowels
on which the the accent Falls are aa e e
o let's take an example for example Gaza
can't a cafe these are three words in
which one can tell that the accent falls
on the first solo the syllable in the
middle and the last syllable so the main
stress can fold pretty much everywhere
I'd also like to emphasize like it did
before that the syllabus syllabus
syllables preceding the main stress are
pronounced as a high tone and the ones
that follow the main tries to pronounce
neutral tone in Chinese that means work
for example gah dah today so in this in
this example Gong is a high tone da is
the main stress array is a neutral Silla
and same goes for cafe in this case
there is no neutral because the main
stress falls on the last syllable cafe
now another peculiarities of the Italian
language is latch onto the frazzle that
means that the main stress the the the
words are taken in the context of a
whole sentence and then Italian the
speaker tends to emphasize some words in
within the same sentence for example if
we say cumin bone which took effect it
means that the speaker once emphasized
that the coffee he or she is talking
about is pretty good so the sense of
will become a born on quiz like affair
or keeping solace in Pataca in in this
sentence to keep sympathic as underlined
because it's the main stress of the
whole sentence and another sentence may
actually be done total Marion Thalia in
this in this context Tonto and Italia
are the main words of the sentence
because Tonto it is I liked so much to
go back to Italy the speaker wants to
emphasize that the the intensity of his
or her desire and the place where they
want to go they want to come back so
this is this is the marker for the main
stress of the sentence as you can see
there can be one one main word or two
main stresses within a saying the same
sentence now as you can see in the
examples Italian aggregates groups of
words and this aggregate
nation of groups of words determines the
vocal tissue as I call it of the whole
sentence that means that aggregating the
choice of aggregating words also
determines how vowels are supposed to be
pronounced if for example the main
stress falls on on on up above let's
take a block of three words like you
personal sympathy got like we did before
this in this sentence sympathy gets the
mean a word that means the the main
stress and all and it's considered as a
single word so as I told you all the
syllabus that precede the the main
stress which falls on pops emphatic are
pronounced high and so this is three
words that are pronounced differently if
they are taken separately so there
they're going to have this special
configuration means so Cape Asuna
sympathy kheh another important thing
for the intonation general is inserting
micro pauses between words micro pauses
between blocks of words for example when
introducing something new body si chiama
Davide you could have shown sakku tea
dose in this sentence that you can see
just here you have new padre pause micro
pause see gamma dot Micropulse echo no
shunsaku because this gift also this is
also important for the time so nation
and also wanted to add that there is
double consonants for in which is a
peculiarity of the Italian language so
we can take an example is Paolo in this
sentence polo is pronounced open brought
a full loop so Paul is Paul for example
North Pole and polo Nord and pull low as
if chicken is full look so the marker is
this is this one because the we have to
emphasize the fact that the voice falls
on on the vowel
preceding the group of the two
consonants and then gives force to the
consonant and also add that in every
language here's interrogation question
mark which is a
this one and the corresponding rro that
I use there's an arrow that I use in
order to emphasize the fact that the
voice is going up and is rising so to
say and then there's the what I call a
punto disc lamotte ciona which is this
one and and I use another are descending
that means that the voice is going down
because it's a wants to express for
example the speaker wants to express
surprise or amazement etc etc ah these
are some markers and I would like to
read a whole text in order to let you
see how I fly intact Santeria here in
pass to Demeter giornata C comma pranzo
in italia a general meant a pass taupe
importante de la giornata Ocasio career
registrar a una resent a very own della
con su a - Deena Supra two-tone Le
Grande ochita que per se gens le lavoro
a new transfer motto il pranzo innuendo
Jarosz Contino
consume ato for Icaza nella sua forma
tradicional a y pranzo comprende piu
port at un primo piatto in di solito
pasta un Segundo piatto majore mentok
arm a un contorno diver Durio patate
seguido donde ser o fruta as you can see
in this you can see dia the phonetic
analysis applied on the screen and so
you can see the pauses you can see the
intonation you can see how the vowels
are supposed to be pronounced and how
group of words are attached together the
conclusion is the if you if you apply
this point at analysis you will realize
that it takes a little bit of time and
by the time you have we you have
completed this analysis the analysis of
the whole text or a dialogue II well you
will have seen that you have listened to
the dialogue itself numerous times it's
and well it's a time it is worth the
time because the main goal is to pay
attention to the small details that you
will not normally pay attention to if
you were just listening
reading briefly the text now a lot of
people and a lot of videos on YouTube
talk about accent reduction but what
about accents foundation means you don't
have to reduce your act you have to
build it by understanding how oh how the
speaker of a foreign language speak
that's that's something better if you
start if you start well in a sigh and we
say Co Machado Bennett who detested
ambit a lot but it means that a good
start is already half of the path so
thank you very much for listening to me
you can find more informations here
which is my blog with all the phonetic
analysis done in detail so thank you
very much and see you in the next videos
bye